[Music]
[Music]
we're joining you from according to some
new fangled research and what a jolly
old time it is to education has become
compulsory for children Queen Vicki is
still on the throne and you'll never
guess what
married women can now own a home of
their own I say progression at its
finest although I won't be getting rid
of the maid cook and Butler any time
soon isn't that right hang on I am not
happy with this well it was the best of
times it was the worst of times
and it was fun for the pledge while it
lasted now back to cars smartphones
Wi-Fi and a bow on toast for me much
better do you mind I was in the middle
of something they're coming up on your
21st century pledge Michelle says Preeti
Patel can't solve the north/south divide
Joon thinks it's time to improve state
education Rachel's got a mystery to
solve
Nick wants voters to provide compulsory
photo ID but first it's me even a 6-0
euro qualifier win by England on Monday
wasn't enough to supersede news of the
game being stopped twice due to the
bulgarian fans racist behavior including
Nazi salutes and monkey chanting racism
is reemerging in football because racism
is reimagine in society overall on that
same day I was labeled a terrorist and
an Uncle Tom in a corner shop amidst an
onslaught of racist abuse online from
Scottish nationalists yes you heard me
correctly for arguing that it's folly
for
Minister to grant another Scottish
referendum a day later spiked online
sought to defend our Home Secretary by
arguing that the only reason the left
dislike her is because she's a
right-wing immigrant miss Patel was born
in London England
I'm tired of arguing why we are not
immigrants seeking a hospitality and
certainly not your inferiors but your
equals I thought my generation had
already fought this battle but something
rotten is engulfing us again and as ufs
president urged us to wage war on the
racists I can't help but feel that we've
all been here before Madge I'm really
sorry to hear that you were racially
abused after that game I mean it was an
abhorrent spectacle I think we can all
agree that what we saw at that match was
despicable and UEFA has to do everything
it can to stamp out racism in football
but as you correctly say as well
football reflects society and what we've
what we see is a sort of bubbling up of
some nasty undercurrents of nationalism
and sort of far-right sectarian activity
which they're using football as a
platform for this manifestation I think
South the England my players because of
their experiences in our own country are
hardened to racism and I don't know what
that says about our society but that's
the reality throughout this I know that
whatever we do might be perceived as not
being enough but I think we've made a
major statement I think we've made a
major statement with the way we played
through such a difficult circumstance so
he's also pointing to the fact that this
is a problem in wider society and
perhaps is a problem here at home as
well clearly it's a problem in Bulgaria
but I think it's easy for us sometimes
in examples such as this to forget that
we have had these problems here in the
UK for a while now even particularly
with with football I remember doing a
very similar topic to this this time
last year when
Rose said that he was thinking about
leaving football because of the racism I
do think of course we have these
problems here no question but actually I
think the FA has done quite a lot to try
and stamp out racism in English football
not enough but we also have to be clear
that this stuff is heightened in a lot
of these Eastern European countries that
our players go to play in and UEFA has
done almost nothing and I think it's got
to the point where if I was one of those
players I have to say I'm not going
anymore
why put yourself through it perhaps we
need something as harsh as that where
England says until UEFA does something
serious there are gonna be countries
that our players don't go to just tell
you what your wafers say UEFA sanctions
are among the toughest in sport for
clubs and associations whose supporters
are racist at our matches the minimum
sanction as a partial closure of the
stadium a move which cost the hosts at
least hundreds of thousands in lost
revenue attaches a stigma to their
support as they go on UEFA is committed
to doing everything it can to eliminate
this disease Danny Rose made in his
piece was that the yes finds may be high
for your average person for the amount
of money that those clubs are making
it's nothing I have an apology to make
okay because in the past I might have
written an indeed said that our football
players are amongst the most overpaid
over cosseted who would fall down as if
they've been felled by a sniper if they
were merely touched inside the penalty
box
I got it totally wrong they were superb
and the way Gareth Southgate marshaled
them insured them as the manager typical
English or British diplomacy there was a
lie over which he wasn't going to go he
would listen to everybody he showed his
passion but he was calm he was tore up
but he let it be known he was sooo
pondered about pre no telly only it's
not me oh boy Englishmen sitting at home
watching if they want to play on the
Pope if they want to come off they come
off the truth of the matter is
absolutely
June said you APHIS fines I had to tell
you what they say what a pile of
footballs utter nonsense
the fines they levy sometimes sometimes
sixteen thousand pounds Montenegro and
Serbia
it means the week's wages Gareth
Southgate and his team we have to
acknowledge that UEFA also sanctioned
the English team for interrupting the
national anthem and not providing enough
stewards should we just hear what the
Labour MP has to say about what she
thinks UEFA should be doing to stop this
UEFA has a duty to act here the world is
watching a fine is not enough so I am
asking our government to ensure that we
are backing up the FA to seek the
harshest possible punishment stadium
bans are a must
forfeiting matches and expulsion from
tournaments must not be ruled out well
that is quite draconian I think Michelle
one is convinced that we're describing
you know what the scenes at that
football match were absolutely
disgusting but I think we do also have
to get a bit of context because that was
probably around fifty people in a
stadium of what 15 20,000 people they
weren't football fans they were there as
a cause problem to deflect attention to
themselves and their stupid cause and
actually we've played right into their
hands because we're not sitting here
talking about a fantastic victory and
achievement by the English team we're
sitting here giving these people what
they want which is attention to their
cause but we need to protect our play no
we can't ignore them but actually they
should have been it was very clear that
they were there to cause trouble they
were sitting there with their eyes
visible and everything concealed and
they should have been grabbed ahold of
and chucked out way before they actually
were and I just think that actually
we've just got to be careful about the
expectations we're putting on two
football clubs that the MP day is
talking about portions from tournaments
and things the last thing you do with
racism and keep it in the dark
when I think about things people like
John Barnes for example who speaks out
terribly well in terms of racism he's
got really strong robust views and he's
constantly getting called an Uncle Tom
when he I think they're two different
issues I want to agree with what you
just said there about keeping it in the
dark and shining a light on it because
actually I made that mistake so I grew
up thinking as I said in my introduction
I thought we had defeated this problem
and during the first this is my miracle
during Obama's first year of presidency
I actually entertained the idea we could
be moving to a post-racial era and that
was my huge mistake I was too optimistic
actually what I realized subsequently
which we all now see and of course I
have a scar on my forehead to testify to
it is that actually it was always there
hidden under the rocks and all it
required was for somebody to to knock
the rock over and all those bugs came
out and magic just to pick up Michele
and your point it wasn't just a hard
core of fans at times it was the whole
crowd chanting and this has happened a
few times to our players when they go to
certain Eastern European countries and I
think we have to be honest about that
anyway back to what you were saying
about the players handling themselves so
graciously let's hear what Tyrone Ming's
had to say it was obviously disappointed
but I think the way that we handled it
and appropriate steps that were in place
and the protocol that the team and us as
players followed I think was effective
so obviously disappointing to go through
what we went through but very proud of
everybody that of the way that we
handled it and ultimately let the foot
we'll do the talking Tyron means Aston
Villa first he was on debut for England
he flew his family out to Sofia he's not
come through at football academies he's
comes through non-league football he did
a regular job he's playing for England
he gets called all those names he's got
mum and dad and everybody has credited
him and all the other we are going to
refuse to play all the players the
Bulgarian first we're not accepting this
from our family the pointed that they
didn't do a bit more than they could of
did you hear the England fans there's a
lovely chant that you call the players
name he's one
our own and they deliberate all the
black lads Marcus Rushford he's one of
our own Tyron beings he's one of it and
the fans from the manager through the
players to the fans
those boys became men on that football
stadium they really did there is a
positive way of as well as that is it
does have that potential to unite us all
again I think it does require spectacles
like this one to make people finally
realize actually for about a couple of
years now people have been raising the
alarm bells but others may have been
slow on the uptake that brings out this
this genie obviously everyone's say that
quick you're talking about the rise of
nationalism but these are people
supporting their national side so of
course you're going to see nationalism
playing this because what I found
interesting is when I watch some of the
media and how they do tree for example
young back black players it's not
particularly well in comparison to their
white place the following day after the
game I found it quite fascinating to
found those set to see those same media
outlets that have been stoking racism in
some ways you know we're in this
together we weren't tolerant really has
a very very strong role to play this a
need to do better
halftime and oranges now for that one
team as we move on